hi everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my hellboy video for the ending of
the movie as well as the two different
post-credits scenes make sure you stay
through the entire movie if you haven't
seen it yet
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i do easter eggs every week we're
getting ready for game of thrones season
eight so it's gonna be crazy tomorrow
and of course careful for spoilers if
you have not seen the hellboy movie yet
so at the end of the movie he stands
victorious he's defeated the blood queen
pulled excalibur out of the stone
claiming his birthright as the right and
true king of the british isles they make
a joke about that later like yeah i
guess i am still king of england
you don't see the sword so presumably he
stuck it back in the stone or
it's in safe keeping so that no one else
can try to use it the sword excalibur is
crazy
powerful you only see a fraction of what
it can do during the actual movie and
they really only used it in that
nightmare sequence
i'll talk about that in a second he
throws the blood queen's head
into the underworld before all the
portals close but she gives them this
prophecy while she's going out that
they're going to see each other again on
the end of days when the actual
armageddon prophecy comes true the
prophecy
that he will lead about the destruction
of the world before you get the post
credits there's a bit of a time jump and
they're on a new bprd mission
dymo is officially a member of the team
seemingly embracing his role a little
bit more
alice is with him they go to take down
an evil team of scientists that are
experimenting on something they don't
know what
but when they barge in they find what
winds up being abe sapiens tank
so presumably if they continue with the
franchise they're just saying that abe
sapien will join the team
in the next film but who knows that
that's going to happen i think it just
depends on how the bacchus office does
the story of abe sapien is actually
pretty fascinating they didn't really
spend too much time on it in the
original hellboy movies
but he actually began life as a normal
human called langdon everett call
he was a victorian era scientist who was
about 70 years old he was a member of
this occult society to believe life and
all knowledge came from the sea
they found and rescued what they thought
was a jellyfish-like deity from
underwater ruins
but the creature escaped and used its
magical power to turn
langdon everett call into the abe sapien
that you see today
then that society believing that he was
the reborn form of the deity that they
worshipped
sealed his body in a tube more than a
hundred years later he was found by
workers in 1978 performing work on the
basement of a hospital
he was still in his tube the reason why
they named him abe sapien is because
there was a piece of newspaper
from the day that abraham lincoln was
assassinated in 1865
so technically his name is abraham
sapien but then that's when they took
him to the bprd and they experimented on
him for a long time until hellboy felt
sorry for him
convinced his father to put abe on the
team and they became fast friends
thereafter
they had a brief tutorial on the film
about how exactly hellboy is connected
to king arthur and how it was that his
mother wound up marrying
azazel and giving birth to him down in
the underworld it's really crazy but you
have to understand that his mother was a
witch that descends from morgan lafaye
her name was sarah hughes she came from
a long line of witches that can trace
their lineage back to mordred
and morgan le pay she married azaizo
when she was 16.
remember she's a witch azazel can give
her power he's very convincing
so it makes sense that she was part of
this supernatural world that it'd be
easier for her to fall in with the zazel
but you have to imagine in the
background he was sort of manipulating
her because he wanted to bring about
this prophecy that would lead to the
apocalypse the ode jihad being released
the weird thing about hellboy's birth
though is is that yes she got married to
azazel
and conceived hellboy but she didn't
give birth to him till much much later
so she was actually taken back to the
earth she wound up having two more
children
they entered the clergy then as part of
a deal with the zazel
as long as they could protect her from
azazel for three nights
his claim on her would be broken he
arrived on earth
killed her human children took her to
the underworld
and then that's when hellboy was born so
hellboy was connected to king arthur via
mordred which is a much darker way to
connect them but king arthur camelot
very tragic tale so it makes sense that
they would use that for the hellboy
backstory
the cool thing about excalibur that they
don't really get into during the movie
they just let you know that it has a lot
of powers he's sort of raising a bunch
of demons using it
but you can also use it to call on the
former knights
of england anyone that's ever been a
knight and died you can raise up from
the grave to fight for you
so imagine a giant army of undead
knights fighting for hellboy
against the armies of darkness the sword
itself does continue to be a big thing
in future hellboy story so i don't know
if they're going to bring it back in
whatever sequel but it exists
it's there hellboy's claimed it so it's
possible for him to use it again when
necessary
but then you get to the mid credit scene
so after a bit of the credits play you
get a scene with hellboy at his father's
grave getting drunk when all of a sudden
the ghost of lobster johnson who you saw
earlier in the film shows up to give him
a pep talk
saying you did a great job in the battle
but now it's time to prepare for the war
he makes a joke about seeing the claw i
bet you want to see the claw everyone
wants to see it it's very
tongue-in-cheek you probably recognize
thomas hayden church i think it was a
great performance as long as you
understood that it was supposed to be a
little bit silly
hellboy loses his [ __ ] they cut to more
credits then in the final post-credits
scene you see baba yaga again
inside her special pocket dimension in
her little chicken leg house on the
mountain there
talking to a mysterious figure asking
him to take down hellboy
and give her the eye that hellboy
promised her in exchange for her help
earlier in the film that was why they
did that really gross kiss between her
and hellboy to seal the deal
why do you have hair on your tongue a
lot of people were confused about what's
going on in this scene
the mercenary that she's speaking to on
the other side of the table speaks with
a really thick accent is probably coche
the deathless a really badass
killer whose soul she possesses and
controls that's why she says i'll grant
your greatest wish if you're successful
i'll allow you to finally die
so that actually takes place during the
darkness calls storyline which they
actually pulled from a little bit for
the movie
they sort of combine a couple different
hellboy comic book arcs to make the plot
of the movie
a little bit of the wild hunt and a
little bit of darkness calls the coche
the deathless storyline where he goes
after hellboy is during the darkness
call storyline though
so presumably that would be to be the a
or the b story for whatever sequel they
do
and in terms of whatever big conflict
they want to do what they might do for
the sequel is incorporate a little bit
more of the conquering worm storyline
which they did a little bit of during
the first hellboy movie where they try
to unleash the augdu jihad
the right hand of doom is what his
father grafted onto his hand his father
azazel
grafted the hand onto him so that
hellboy would be able to free the augdu
jihad on the world
unleashing the apocalypse when hellboy
is confronted with excalibur the first
time and merlin tells him take the sword
before it disappears and he has the
nightmare vision of what could come to
pass
he's riding that huge dragon before he
lands the feet of the blood queen and
starts eviscerating all the hordes of
people
that's a bit of a wink at the ogden
jihad although that dragon was not
it it's actually much much larger they
did a much better version of it during
that first hellboy movie
[Music]
but in the flashback when they're
explaining how he was summoned from the
underworld they do the version of his
origin story you see rasputin captured
by the authorities he's presumably still
alive
in the comics rasputin actually makes a
bargain with baba yaga
who takes part of his soul hides it in
the world tree so that he can never
fully die even if his body is destroyed
they also did a little bit of that
during the first tell boy movie where
they bring him back to life but in
darkness calls and future stories you
get a bit more of baba yaga
versus hellboy and her sort of using her
crazy powers to try and take him down
rasputin coche the deathless just wind
up being pawns in her game to try and
get him
so if it wasn't clear they were trying
to tell you that baba yaga is going to
continue to be a really
really big hellboy villain although
there's a lot of other really big
mythological things going on in the
background
they don't really get too much into
their backstory during the film but the
whole reason why baba yaga lost her eye
and hates hellboy so much because of the
previous encounters they had they've
actually run into each other a couple
times but the time that she keeps
referring to is the first encounter that
they had that's when she lost her eye
way back in 1964 hellboy encountered her
while investigating a string of missing
child
cases so found out that baba yaga was
stealing the children to eat them they
sort of pay reference to that during the
film you see all the little skeletal
hands
so back in 1964 when hellboy finds her
while she's counting the fingers of a
bunch of dead children in the cemetery
during the attack she loses her left eye
it shoots right out she curses the
village that they're in
all the children wind up being born
blind in one eye but that's when her
power diminishes and she gets trapped in
that pocket dimension
created in the image of her version of
russia as it appeared a long time ago
but within the recurring hellboy stories
every once in a while she is allowed to
come back into our dimension
once you have a chance to see the film
let me know what you thought of it in
the comments below critics are ripping
it apart so i don't know how well it's
going to do there were a couple things
that i thought it did well
but there's a lot of stories behind the
scenes about drama between the director
the producers the studio so who knows
what's going to happen with it i guess
we'll find out in the next couple of
weeks
what's gonna happen next is is they're
doing a panel for star wars the
mandalorian tv series that's gonna be
happening later this year they'll
release a trailer at that
if they put it online i'll do a
breakdown of it and then obviously game
of thrones season eight episode one
is happening sunday night i'll post my
video a little while after it airs as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all the videos when i
post them so no worries
while you wait for everything click here
to get ready for game of thrones season
8 episode 1
and click here to re-watch that star
wars episode 9 trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight